Here's something that should
keep developers up at night.
Governments trying
to weaken encryption.
This audience
knows how important
encryption is to keeping
information safe and secure.
Encryption stops snoopers from
viewing the contents of emails
and searches and
prevents hackers
from getting access to
your sensitive information.
But there's been a growing
concern from some governments
that encryption is
getting too strong,
hindering legitimate
criminal investigations.
In fact, just this
summer, a hearing
was held in Congress
called, "Going
Dark-- Encryption, Technology,
and the Balance Between Public
Safety and Privacy."
And over the last year,
government officials
have thrown around
terms like golden keys,
meaning that companies should
create a set of master keys
that allow government
agencies a backdoor
to decrypt any communication
when they need to decrypt it.
And variants of this sort
of approach are spreading.
For instance, France
recently passed a law
that requires that secret
code designed by the National
Intelligence Agency be injected
into service providers'
infrastructure.
Now if this debate sounds
familiar, that's because it is.
Back in the 1990s,
the White House
pushed the clipper chip,
a system of key escrow
in which a copy of each
chip's unique encryption key
would be stored
by the government.
Encryption was even classified
as munitions in the United
States with strict limits
on the type of encryption
that could be exported and
the maximum key length.
So what changed?
Well for one,
there were concerns
about appropriate oversight
and accountability
for government
access to user data
and the harms to
commerce and innovation
if people couldn't trust
that their information was
safe and secure.
Moreover, as security expert
Bruce Schneier has put it,
"You can't build a backdoor
that only the good guys
can walk through."
Encryption protects
against cybercriminals,
industrial competitors,
the Chinese secret police,
and the FBI.
We are either vulnerable to
eavesdropping by any of them,
or we're secure from
eavesdropping from all of them.
That's as true today
as it was in the '90s.
In fact, Schneier and a
group of computer scientists
recently released a paper
explaining in detail
why backdoors are a bad idea.
Of course, law enforcement
needs tools to ferret out
illegal activity, and
governments have a duty
to protect their citizens.
Flush it out, but through the
front door not a backdoor,
by getting permission
from a judge
and using traditional,
time-tested legal processes
like getting a warrant.
That's this edition
of "What Should
Keep Developers Up At Night."
Sleep soundly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]